okay
so most of you already received this
flyer
and in the flyer we have a um link here
that actually shows uh
like if you click in on the link it will
take you to the website and you you will
see that there is a form that you have
to submit
uh so that we know that the people are
interested in this course
and once you submit this form we will
send you notification and other
information about the courses so this is
what the course schedules are so the
first course the introduction to
bioinformatics starts in january 24th
that is next week and it's pretty much a
month long course
the second uh course the genomics and
genomic data analysis starts on the 25th
of january and it's a little bit longer
than the first course it ends on the
march 22nd
and you can either take the genomics or
the metagenomics data analysis
and
last course starts on january 27 until
april 21st
so to
um
before you take this courses you have to
register through lsu um most more
specifically
via the gene lab
so to register it first of all you have
to have an ilab
account
so after this orientation session i will
send you all the links and
important informations on how to
register
so first you need to create an account
in the ilab
or the gene lab the people who are
already in the lsu vet school you guys
already use the ilab for utilizing some
of the instruments it's a core facility
for us
whoever doesn't have the account they
have to sign up and sometimes some of
the students uh already face this issue
that their pis names are not on the link
on this system so for those people they
have to
like inform us their pi name
email address
and phone number so that we can include
the pi in this system so once you have
the
once you sign up
once you sign up
for an account you will see a page like
this
and then
i will scroll down
here just call down here and
you have to create an account and then
you sign in
and after you sign in
you will see uh
on the left hand side the core
facilities
you have to click on that core
facilities and then you will see
uh the course cedar core facilities and
services you have to click on that
and after that you will see a page like
this
and then on the right side on top corner
you will see the request services
so
it will take you to the
training module
once you click on the request service
it will take you to the training module
and you can see and select like what are
the courses that you are interested in
whether you are
in taking the one course the first
course or all of them you will select
those courses
and then
right now you don't see it here but if
the updated system will have the names
of the courses then you can
select it
afterwards you have to put the phone
number
if you are outside the lsu or they'll be
in program then you have to have your
specific fund number
for us otherwise you just write lsu or
lprn
and then we will put the account number
here so after that you will just have to
submit the request to us and we will go
through all the information and then
we'll accept it and then the
registration will be complete
so after this orientation session i will
i will send you all about the
informations and everything
and the procedure how to register so
that if there's any confusion you can
look at it and after that if there's any
other questions i would be happy to help
you just contact me
that's it i